depuis une petite moi c'est les enfants
donc belge poursuit cette branche l'or
depuis la rentrée scolaire colline
schlaeppi 22 ans est en formation ces
apps et accompagnement éducatif petite
enfance au sein de l'association des
cours professionnels de pharmacie santé
sanitaire et social à voici qu'on
apprend tout le sommeil on apprend la
nutrition on apprend
comment réagir face à un enfant qui qui
mécontents qui fait une crise on apprend
vraiment tout autour de l'enfant en fait
en alternance dans l'entreprise bay
beach ou services coline coupe sa
journée en deux le matin elles assistent
aux cours et l'après midi elle garde des
enfants le ca permet de réviser la
partie théorique tout le côté nutrition
de l'enfant tout côté sécurité d'enfants
également tout le côté éveil le côté
psychomoteur également c'est une
formation il sape et s'adresse vraiment
à la garde d'enfants de 0 à 6 ans
l'après-midi colline va chercher à
l'école aloïs et gustave cela fait sept
mois qu'elle s'occupe de ses enfants du
lundi au vendredi de 16 heures à 19
heures 15 tout dépend en fait des gens
des ya des jours où il ya des activités
sportives donc du coup je suis plus avec
aloïs je vais le chercher en premier on
rentre directement sans le petit on fait
les voir les goûters et après je
l'emmène et ensuite je vais chercher le
petit quand tu irais du temps baroin on
joue on lit on met de la musique on sent
bien et on a montré que l'hymne en
septembre et ça s'est fait très
naturellement que le dîner
super réactive très apprécié des enfants
un vrai plaisir au quotidien brède b
bijoux services spécialisée dans la
garde d'enfants à domicile met en
relation leurs alternant et des familles
qui ont des besoins spécifiques pour les
apprenants le terrain leur fournit des
compétences gagne en autonomie en
maturité professionnelle sens de
l'organisation
répondre aux objectifs qui sont fixées
par par l' agence mais sans fixer soi
même aussi au jour le jour les agences
babychou services de versailles
saint-germain-en-laye et
maisons-laffitte organise un job dating
dédié à l'alternance le 27 avril
prochain le but recruté 80 postes
d'alternants pour septembre 2022